new findings indicate coronavirus was
circulating in California weeks earlier
than previously thought
autopsies on two people who died in
Northern California on February 6th and
February 17th show they were victims of
kovat 19 previously the earliest known
fatality was on February 29th in
Washington State the findings may mean
that dozens of times more people
nationwide have been exposed and have
died than has been officially reported
California was the first to issue a
statewide stay-at-home order on
Wednesday Governor Gavin Newsom outlined
his approach to gradually and cautiously
lifting restrictions there is no light
switch and there is no date in terms of
our capacity to provide the kind of
clarity that I know so many of you
demand and deserve Newsom said as a
first step scheduled surgeries for non
kovat 19 conditions may resume tumors
heart valves the need for people to get
the kind of care that they deserve it's
if it's delayed it becomes ultimately
denied it gets delayed it becomes acute
Newsom said further relaxing of
restrictions would depend on data based
on increased testing and contact tracing
we want to focus on science and health
as a predicate for all our
decision-making
California's cautious and gradual
approach contrasts sharply with
decisions by Republican governors in
southern states like Georgia and Florida
to reopen Beach's gyms beauty salons and
tattoo parlors among other businesses
public health officials have strongly
warned against a premature reopening of
businesses and public gatherings saying
that would almost certainly lead to a
new surge in Kovach 19 infections and
deaths rob reynolds al jazeera los
angeles